Faust was the mythical figure who sold
his soul to the devil for unlimited
power now remember that Japan has no
energy resources of its own it does not
have oil does not have coal has a little
bit of hydropower so it is dependent on
nuclear energy to keep that economy
going and that economy is huge we're
talking about the third largest economy
on the face of the earth but what does
an economy like that mean if it's based
on nuclear and one tsunami
can simply wipe out scores of nuclear
power plants this is going to force
every industrialized nation to
reevaluate the Faustian bargain Germany
has already announced that it may begin
the process of closing down reactors in
that country in the United States we
also have a crisis because we have old
reactors just like in Japan in the
United States we haven't had a new order
for a nuclear power plant since before
Three Mile Island 1979 we're dealing
with really old reactors and they have
to be decommissioned this means that the
United States is undergoing a sea change
with regards to a new generation of
power plants what will replace all these
aging nuclear power plants we may even
have to rethink whether or not nuclear
is the best option at all because the
question is let's say that the Fukushima
reactor was new could it withstand 9.0
and the answer is probably no so even if
you were to brace a reactor even if you
were to add more redundant safety
systems I doubt that it could withstand
a one-two punch from a 9.0 earthquake
and tsunami think of driving a car I
driving a car that's out of control what
do you do you hit the brakes
well the brakes don't work it's still
out of control and then the radiator
blows up and you say to yourself oh my
god next is the gas tank the gas tank is
going to go what do you do you run it
into a river that's exactly what they
did in Japan first the brakes didn't
work because the tsunami wiped out the
backup system then the core is heated up
cause a hydrogen gas explosion
that's your radiator blowing up and then
when they do they ran it into the river
that's the same thing as dumping
seawater on these nuclear power plants
and of course to keep the seawater going
you have to have power and they don't
have power and meanwhile radiation
levels rise to the point where it's near
lethal so you're cut in this bind even
if that reactor was a new reactor so
some people are saying maybe we should
rethink our commitment to nuclear at all